you're having a fantastic moment aren't
you how does it feel and tell me a
little bit about your role in the film
tonight that you've won this for oh well
um it feels it feels kind of ridiculous
it's all yeah it's going to go wrong but
I played the Queen Mum insert set in
1939 and it was a lovely part to play
with lovely people with no Bill Murray
and sand west living Williams and just
beautiful Laura Linney no it was hardly
a difficult thing to do and you've got
lots of stuff coming up as we working
with rashida Jones and Nick Frost and
Chris Oh dad as well on cuban fury and
you've also got i give it a year cuban
fury is this beautiful film where Nick
Frost and I play brother and sister them
and Nick was a salsa champion and then
something happened and he stopped
dancing and cut to Nick Frost now who's
fall in love with someone in the office
and finds out i hope i'm not doing
terrible spoilers and after i'm loud so
but she said she loves dancing and it's
his journey back to him does he do it
doesn't it but he's he's an amazing
dancer yeah he's amazing and you a good
dancer no no no no no they cut around it
very well and I give it here dan dan
mazer he wrote and directed it is an old
friend of mine and and he sent me the
script and it's just a time that apart
but it's really fun to do so it was a
real foul mouth potty mouth rant she's
always nice to do
you